Sal Khan here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to the "Homeroom
with Sal" livestream.
We have a very exciting show today.
We have, I would say two mega figures
in the world of education.
We have Carol Dweck.
Professor at Stanford .
Y'all might know her for
her really pioneering work
around "Growth Mindset."
Really coined the term.
Author of "Mind Shift."
We also have Vicky Colbert.
Who's the executive director of
the "Escuela Nueva" Foundation.
"Fundacion Escuela Nuev."
Which is a really
incredible series of schools
and a new learning model
through Latin America.
That has made huge impact on the world.
Both of them are actually the first,
I believe the first two
winners of "The Yidan Prize"
in education globally.
So we have two titans of education.
So, start thinking of your questions
for either Carol or Vicky.
But before we do that.
I will give some of my
standard announcements.
First of all, reminder that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit.
We can only do what we
do because of donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you can.
Go to khanacademy.org/donate.
And whatever you're capable of.
It could make a huge difference.
If you're in a position to do so.
Also wanna give a shout out
to several organizations
that stepped up.
Especially during the pandemic.
Many of y'all know that our traffic grew
by a factor of 3 during the pandemic.
And our costs went up.
And we tried to accelerate
a whole series of programs.
And so we wouldn't have
been able to do that
without the support of
the folks on the screen.
Bank of America.
AT&T.
Google.org.
Novartis.
Fastly.
General Motors.
And many other supporters,
large and small.
Who allow Khan Academy
to build what we do.
And create the content that we do.
Last but not least.
I wanna remind folks
that there's a version
of this livestream that
you can get wherever
you get your podcasts.
"Homeroom with Sal," the podcast.
So with that, I am very
excited to introduce
both Carol and Vicky.
Carol and Vicky, welcome.
- Thank you.
- Hi Sal.
Great to be here with you.
- So I wish I could have
two hours with each of you.
There's a lot for us to cover.
But maybe I'll start with you, Carol.
I think a lot of folks
who've been in education.
Know about "growth mindset."
But if you could tell me,
for anyone who has been
under a rock for the last several decades.
What is a "growth mindset."
And why has it caught the "Zeitgeist"
so to speak of education?
And maybe a little bit of what are the
misconceptions around it?
(gasps)
- Thanks Sal.
A "growth mindset" is the belief that
your fundamental abilities are not fixed.
But can be developed.
It's in contrast to a fixed mindset.
Where, the belief is your
abilities are genetically based.
Or in some way fixed.
And, you are what you are.
And you have what you have.
And that's how you stay.
I think the "growth mindset"
caught on for several reasons.
First.
We've done decades of work showing how,
and students believe that their
abilities can be developed.
They have greater motivation to learn.
They're, less afraid
to take on challenges.
Less discouraged by mistakes.
They're developing something.
They're not afraid of it's
being judged deficient.
This was a new way of seeing students.
Seeing them not as
people that you sort into
the smart and not smart.
But people you can develop.
Help them realize their full potential.
I think it's exciting for teachers
to believe that every single
child in front of them
has unknown potential that you can unlock.
Now, some of the misconceptions.
It's not always so intuitive.
How you communicate a "growth
mindset" to your students.
So some teachers thought,
just tell them to work hard.
Tell them you can learn anything.
Tell them everyone's smart.
But, what we have found over time is that.
"Growth mindset" is a classroom culture.
It's not something you say to kids.
Or put a poster in front of the room.
It's something that you
bake into the culture
of the classroom.
And have all kinds of
practices that support it.
Like making sure every
student knows you care
about their learning.
Believe they can learn to a high level.
Making sure they know
you think they can learn
from their mistakes.
The mistakes don't mean
they're incompetent.
Letting kids redo work
to raise their grade
and demonstrate their understanding.
Focusing on the progress,
not immediate performance.
So now we're really focused on this idea
of the "growth mindset,"
classroom culture.
That fosters and empowers the students
to use their "growth mindsets."
- And one follow question before,
I think what Vicky's work
is very complimentary
to everything you just talked about.
But I'm curious, Carol.
And I've never asked you this.
What got you into this research?
What was the reason
that you kind of started
formulating this whole theory
around "growth mindset" and testing it?
- If I can start in childhood.
But I'm not gonna go every year.
And if you ask me who's my
most influential teacher.
It's Mrs. Wilson.
My 6th grade teacher.
Who seated us around the room in IQ order.
- [Sal] Wow.
- And I thought, "When you
try to ask a 6th grader,"
I thought, "This is so wrong."
I know the kids in this class.
I've been with them for years.
You can't sort them
point by point into IQ.
Nonetheless, I was sucked into her system.
I wanted to succeed within her framework.
So years later, when I fell
in love with psychology.
And saw that you could use science
to study people's beliefs, motivations.
I thought, "I'm gonna
study why some children
are able to fulfill their potential
by taking on challenges
and sticking to them."
And other kids who may
be really, really skilled
never achieve what they're capable of.
And in graduate school.
I embarked on the line of
research that I'm still pursuing.
- It's fascinating.
And I definitely wanna come back to that.
But you know, Vicky.
Tell us about "Escuela Nueva."
What was the reason you started it?
And what is the core underlying principle
of what's made it what it is?
- "Escuela Nueva," word in Spanish.
"New School."
Well, first of all.
It's not so new anymore.
It's one of the longest
bottom up innovations
to the developing world.
That's still being sustained.
It's like a pedagogical movement.
Nothing new in the
philosophy of education.
All the things we know
that the great pedagogue
said at the beginning of the century.
Good child centered learning.
Not everybody learns the
same thing at the same time.
Self-paced learning.
Children learn looking into their eyes.
Dialoguing and constructing
knowledge together.
So it's, co-operative learning.
A new role of the teacher, as
a great mentor, a facilitator.
That has more time to really
focus on the human dimension.
So we started thinking about
all these things by necessity.
Because we started with the isolated
rural-multi grade schools.
Invisible schools, of
developing countries.
And of course in Columbia,
where we started.
And, basically we wanted
to introduce these concepts
of good pedagogy.
All these ideas exist, and
have existed for so many years.
With John Dewey, with Maria
Montessori, Lev Vygotsky.
All of these.
But these ideas came
only to the elite schools
in Latin America.
Not to the poorest of the poor.
So I'm originally a sociologist.
And, but of course I
had a wonderful mother.
She was a great teacher.
That did a lot in Columbia.
And founded teacher's colleges.
And she was always talking
about child centered learning.
And, so I had a contrast.
Because of what I received
in good quality schools,
private schools.
And what I was seeing in reality.
With the most isolated,
rural children of Columbia.
So I wanted to introduce
the concept of equity.
We do this in equity.
I wanted to introduce
the concept of really,
child centered learning to
improve quality in education.
21st century skills.
And of course the new role of the teacher.
So these rural schools, there
were so many difficulties
that we really had to
have a paradigm shift
from transmission of knowledge to
social construction of knowledge.
And we really wanted to incorporate
and strengthen the relationship between
citizenship building and your pedagogy.
So I guess these ideas
and the necessity for us.
"Necessity was the mother of innovation."
So I say it's a little bit,
like we had to learn how to transform
all this complexity into
simple, manageable action.
So that anybody, any
teacher without having a PhD
could have results.
So I think these are the little tricks
we have in "Escuela Nueva."
Which means "New School."
And as I said is one of the longest ones
innovations of the developing world.
That's still being sustained.
And that has inspired of course
many innovations worldwide.
Like the Vietnamese, for example.
From Columbia to Vietnam.
- And now there's tens of
thousands of these schools.
I mean, it is at scale.
For anyone who hasn't seen a "New School."
An "Escuela Nueva."
What would it look like?
It sounds very different than
that teacher that Carol had.
Lined up all those students by IQ.
What does it look like?
What would you hear and see?
- Totally.
When you go into a
"Escuela Nueva," school.
You see, it's an example
of democracy in a way.
By the way, we're going through all these
crisis and processes.
But you see some children working
in some things by themselves, in pairs.
Others working in small groups.
Some are going to their learning corners.
It's a learning environment
that has changed.
They're permanently
talking and dialoguing.
And you see a teacher walking around
when children call on the teacher.
Not the other way around.
When the children call on the teacher.
Cause we really want it
to be child centered.
You see the teacher going
through the different groups.
Talking individually with some.
Talking in pairs with others.
You see some children
going out of the classroom
to do an experiment by themselves.
They're working with
their learning guides.
They have their, a lot of
self-governing instruments
to promote a school
government and democracy.
And we really want to
incorporate a culture
of participation.
So they're many little
tricks that we see that
strengthened self-esteem.
Discovery learning.
Child-centered.
Their self-concept.
We want them to really enjoy learning.
And I think we have seen
this in these very isolated
rural schools of Columbia
and of other countries.
Where we have worked with.
- And how did you pull this off?
I mean, I think that's
the most important thing
on a lot of levels.
How did this happen?
I mean I could imagine,
especially if you're going to rural areas.
The teacher's notion of
what a teacher does is very,
probably very traditional.
Someone at a chalkboard, lecturing.
While students have fingers
on lips and listening.
How were you able to manage
the controlled chaos?
So to speak.
Of multiple students working
at their own time and pace.
And you did this even before
Ed Tech became a real tool.
Explain the logistics of it.
And then I actually wanna connect it.
Cause it sounds very complimentary
to everything that Carol was mentioning.
- Totally, totally.
That's why we say with Carol,
we fell in love with each other.
Because Carol coming from such
solid scientific research.
And me coming from such
necessity and complexity.
The question you asked me is,
"How do they know what they're
doing and how they are?"
Well, we had to develop.
First of all.
We had to change the teacher's attitudes.
We wanted to make sure
that teachers be trained
with the same methodology
they will be using
with their students.
Because we're asking
teachers to make the change.
And they've been exposed
to very traditional
teacher centered learning
when they were students.
When they were studying.
So the first thing we had to do was.
Try to change what most
faculties of education,
and teachers colleges are not doing.
So we wanted, that teachers
go through the same process
they will be doing with their children.
Second.
We would like them to see a demo school.
So that they would say, "We can do it."
"It's nothing complicated."
"We can perfectly do this."
And the third thing was.
Not leave the teachers alone.
We had to create a community of practice.
So because teachers learn
more from each other
than from experts.
And of course the whole idea was introduce
the concept of flexibility.
Act, time and space.
We had to introduce a whole
concept of flexibility
in these terms.
And because, learning is not a place.
It's an activity.
Okay?
So, we have learned that many of the most
important activities
take place in their homes
with their parents.
And so we just wanted
to make sure that all
of these ideas were incorporated
in what we were doing.
And we were really transforming
all this complexity
into simple, manageable action.
We have to make it simple.
Simple, replicable,
scalable, and cost-effective.
- No, super powerful.
I'm already getting a ton of
questions from social media.
So I wanna make sure I get to
as many of these as possible.
And these are connected to the work
that both of y'all are doing.
From YouTube.
Joshua Kadavul asks,
"It's very difficult to motivate ourselves
into a growth mindset."
"What do you suggest to help
us get into that mindset?"
I'll start with Carol.
Who knows the science
and the research here.
But then after that.
I'd also love to learn from Vicky.
Because, if all of your
students have this agency.
And it's student centered learning.
I'm assuming a lot of them need
the same "growth mindset" as well.
But Carol, what advice
do you have for Josh
or anyone listening on, how
do you get into that mindset?
- How old is Josh?
- [Sal] I have no idea.
He's on YouTube.
- Okay Josh.
Whether you're a student or an adult.
You have to ask yourself,
"What do you want to do?"
"What do you care about?"
"What do you want to contribute
to the world in your life?"
And then, "How do I get there?"
You'll need to take on challenges.
You'll need to know that everybody
struggles through challenges.
Everybody has setbacks.
It's part of learning.
Your fixed mindset voice
will come back to you a lot.
And say, "This is too hard."
"You were unrealistic."
"You can't do that."
And you have to talk back to it, not.
"Go away."
"I don't like you."
"You're in my way."
But, "Hey, I wanna try this."
"Can you come on board
and collaborate with me?"
"Can you contribute with me?"
"Can you let me try this?"
So, where we all have both mindsets.
The fixed mindset is
ready to track back in
and discourage you, when things are hard.
Or you have a failure.
But, you have to get it on board.
Get it on your side.
And keep in mind, what
you're trying to accomplish.
And who you're doing it for.
- And Vicky, I'll actually
add this extra question
from YouTube, and it actually
turns out Josh is 16.
So I guessed correctly somehow.
I'm clairvoyant in some way.
But from YouTube, there's
a related question.
Julian Miller asks,
"Mrs. Dweck and Vicky,
how would you go about
getting a younger student
with low self-esteem
to gain a growth mindset?"
And Vicky, I love your take first.
Because, I'm assuming you've
essentially had to do this.
I don't know when you
started "Escuela Nueva."
Whether you thought that you
were doing "growth mindset."
But now there's the science
from Carol behind it.
But how have you thought
about motivating kids,
reinforcing a "growth mindset"
versus a "fixed mindset?"
- Yes.
I think the first thing
we wanted to make sure is
that children love school.
That they would have a nice environment
despite that it's a rural isolated school.
That would be a nice pleasant environment.
So, I think that's crucial.
The second thing was.
That they would feel the
love from their teacher.
Not classifying them.
But a teacher that would
always, open the doors to them.
And give them the love and
affection they're needing.
Cause they're really needing
so much affection and love.
And a nice warm place and an environment
where they can be safe.
A wonderful aspect was,
to motivate children.
To intrinsic motivation.
I'm not a psychologist.
I don't know much about it.
But we wanted children to have
a little bit of self-concept.
To know that they could be happy learning.
And we developed all these
very simple instruments
of, to promote autonomy.
To promote self-determination.
The flexibility that
all children can learn
if you give them the time.
And that they don't have to
compete with anybody else.
But that they can go on their own rhythm.
And the motivation, the self-regulation.
They're many, many instruments
of self governing instruments.
Where children control
their own attendance.
Where they have all
these simple instruments
of the school governments.
Where children elected, and are elected.
And they have the school
government, with their projects.
Concrete projects they
have with their parents
and their community.
So we had to think of
all these little tricks
to make sure that any teacher could have
a wonderful classroom
and a nice environment.
That all children could learn
if you give them the time
and a nice safe environment.
So it's a really a whole concept
of child-friendly concept.
That we wanted to embrace.
So the school was a place where children
didn't want to leave.
They wanted to stay.
Because they had a loving teacher.
And they had their classmates
where they worked together.
And they learn to dialogue.
So I mean, they're very simple tricks
that we had to incorporate.
But they've demonstrated
that it can be done.
Yes, we can introduce
quality, reduce inequity.
Incorporate leadership
skills from the beginning.
It's amazing to see these little children
taking responsibilities and
assuming the responsibilities.
And leading others and
learning to work in teams.
I have to say I had a
professor at Stanford.
Elizabeth Cohen.
For the first time I learned
about corporative learning.
Here in Latin America we talk
about personalized learning.
But not corporative learning.
And we have seen the results.
Because, let's say we've always have tried
to have some empirical research behind.
So for example, the University of London
published one of our first research papers
demonstrating the impact
of "Escuela Nueva."
On peaceful, social
interaction of children.
Not only on academic achievement.
But on peaceful behavior.
And I think this is so important,
coming out of Columbia.
Very important.
- No, thanks for that Vicky.
And Carol, same question.
Say there's a younger student that,
how does a parent or a teacher
or anyone who cares about them.
The question was specifically if
they have a low self-esteem
to have a "growth mindset."
Sometimes you've been
that kid where we're like,
"Oh, I'm not good at this."
"My brain isn't wired for that."
What do you tell them?
What do you do?
- Well first, I wanna
say one of the hundreds
or even thousands things I love
about Vicky's work and her schools.
Is that she takes the fixed
mindset off the table.
It doesn't occur to
students in that environment
to worry about being measured.
But, in our culture.
It's really different.
Parents worry about how
smart their children are.
Parents measure them.
Then they go to school, they're tested.
They're compared to each other.
Teachers often decide who's the smart
and who's not as smart.
So, it's not a surprise that
we have a lot of young
students with low self-esteem.
Now, my research and
the research of others
like Eddie Brummelman in the Netherlands.
Shows that sometimes people react to kids
with low self-esteem.
By telling them how smart they are.
Or by over praising them.
Which actually makes them more vulnerable
to failure in the future.
I would say the research suggests
keep the focus on learning.
Keep the focus on progress.
Keep the focus on challenging yourself.
Say to a child who did something easily.
"Oh, I'm sorry."
"I'm sorry, I wasted your time."
"That was too easy for you."
"You must have been bored."
Let's do something fun.
Something you can learn from.
If the child gets stuck and
discouraged on something.
Be that backup support.
Like Vicky's teachers.
Let's see what you've done.
What can you think of, of doing next?
Let's try that.
So this detective process of
what you didn't understand
and how you can understand it.
Make that whole process fun.
We've seen that parents
who believe that failure
can inspire their child's learning.
Are much better mentors to their kids.
Than parents who worry
that their child's failures
will harm them.
And make them feel incompetent.
So this whole focus on
challenge, progress.
Learning from setbacks.
Is, what goes into this
natural love of learning.
As opposed to the self doubt
that comes from feeling
measured and compared.
- Yeah.
And there's a lot of questions coming in.
I mean, this resonates
with anyone listening.
Anyone who at any level of depth on this.
And I think a lot of the
questions are the flavor of,
how do we actually put this
out there in the world?
We've talked about how you
can do it as an individual.
Or how you could even
change your own mindset.
We know we have this question.
I'm paraphrasing from
YouTube, Jamal Shahid.
"How would this look in an urban school?"
From YouTube, Manish Raj Jaiswal.
They're talking about
stereotypical South Asian parents.
That are more grades oriented
versus skill oriented.
How do you change that?
So the broader question
is, how do you scale this?
Cause both of y'all have scaled
this idea in different ways.
Carol, where do you think we are?
Versus where do you think we can be?
And I'll ask Vicky the same question.
Where we are versus where we could be?
- I'll tell you exactly where we are.
We have shown that direct
to student "growth mindset"
programs can work.
They can raise the achievement.
The grades of lower achievers.
They can inspire even higher achievers
to take more advanced math courses.
But, if a student has taken this program
and goes back into say a
mass classroom with a teacher
who's created a fixed minded culture.
They can't put that into practice.
They can't thrive there.
In the special way that
their "growth mindset"
might've allowed them to.
So then we realized.
(gasps)
We have to create a program for teachers.
Just the way Vicky has
created a scalable program.
We realized David Yeager,
Mary Murphy and I.
We realized we've got to have modules
that can scale up.
That we can disseminate widely.
That will prevent teachers from trying
to implement it in ways that don't work.
We're in the middle of that now.
Vicky is a valued, valued
consultant in this project.
This fall, we're gonna test.
Administer and test the
first version of this.
We'll do this the next year as well.
When it's tested and ready.
It will be available at
no cost to all teachers.
We're doing it on an
adolescent population.
It's the hardest thing we've ever done.
It's the most important
thing we've ever done.
And we're working on it around the clock.
- No, thanks for that Carol.
And Vicky.
I mean, you're already at the scale.
I mean, tell me what scale you're at.
I've read tens of thousands of schools.
I don't know how many students that is.
But I'm guessing hundreds of thousands
or millions of students across countries.
So you're already a lot of scale.
But how far do you think
you're on this journey?
Where do you think we
could be in 5 or 10 years?
What's your hope?
- My hope is that we can
continue to move forward.
However, they're many lessons
learned from this process.
Of how to work with whom do you work with.
Going back to your
initial question to Carol.
We sort of had to also
modularize the curriculum.
Curriculums they're like "big beasts."
How do you tackle a national curriculum?
So the first thing is we had
to break it up in chunks.
Modularize it, to facilitate flexibility.
Because we wanted to
incorporate the concept
of self-paced learning and flexibility.
So it's an important aspect
of the "Escuela Nueva."
So the student's ability to progress
through their learning materials.
Their learning guides.
Using both self assessments
and group assessments.
But we believe that this
flexibility has helped a lot.
Because in this way.
Students know that they can achieve.
Even if it was going a little bit slower.
So it's the whole concept of flexibility
that we had to introduce
in the curriculum.
And the way we work with children.
In everything.
So this was for us really, really crucial.
And of course, I mean when we scaled up.
We learned to work with governments.
Which is something that
I have also learned.
You have to work with governments.
Because we learn how to
make it a national policy.
But you need governments
for big impact and coverage.
But you need the role of civil society
and public private
partnerships for two key words.
Quality and sustainability.
They're many countries
where we have started
"Escuela Nueva."
In Brazil.
In Guatemala.
And all these places in Latin America.
Beyond, we've inspired in Zambia.
But the thing is that.
One of the big issues is that
we have inspired many countries.
But, you get that the project started.
It starts moving on.
And then governments change.
So this is another lesson
learned from all this process.
Not only the, let's say
the curriculum dimensions
of how to modularize curriculums.
And make them flexible to adapt.
That the school adapts to the children
and not the other way around.
Because by the way, I have
to highlight the initial way
when we had to make it flexible.
Because children in rural areas
have to walk long distances.
Because children
participate in picking crops
with their parents.
So it's a mobile population.
By the way, we have
adopted "Escuela Nueva"
to urban contexts.
"Escuela Activa Urbana."
And especially for migrants,
and displaced populations.
Right now we're working with many, many
Venezuelan migrants in Colombia.
And it's been a successful program.
Where we adapt, this is
in the cities of Columbia.
Not in the rural areas.
So this is where we adapt
to the needs of the child.
And not the other way around.
That the school really
is open and flexible.
And this is what we
really have tried to do.
And to maintain this flexibility.
I don't know if I answered
your question correctly.
But I picked up on other things.
- No, that was incredibly valuable.
And this is conversation,
I thought we were like
five minutes into it.
Cause I'm so intrigued.
And I realized that we're
pretty much out of time.
And I apologize to everyone.
There's so many good questions
that have been coming in on social media.
But, I'll leave it up to y'all.
Maybe a last word from
either of you on messages
you have for folks who are both
fascinated by these models.
Fascinated by "growth mindset."
But also fascinated by
y'all as individuals.
And are looking to have
similar impact in their life.
What messages would you have for them.
Maybe Carol start.
And then followed by Vicky.
(gasps)
- That's a big one.
First.
I just want to underscore
something Vicky said.
How important equity is in education.
How important it is for schools
to adopt to the culture.
Adapt to the culture
and needs of students.
And some "growth mindset," a
"growth mindset" assessment
into a recent survey and testing.
And found that "growth mindset" not only
predicted achievement.
And much or most of the world of the
79 countries and economies.
But also motivation to learn, wellbeing.
It gave a bigger boost
to vulnerable students,
low income, immigrants.
It narrowed the gap
between the rich and poor.
The immigrants and non-immigrants.
So, we're caring about kids
lives, their wellbeing.
And again, we want to
inspire them to think
about the contributions they wanna make.
I'm worried kids aren't gonna
wanna come back to school
after the pandemic.
They're gonna feel behind.
Lets get them inspired
by a contribution that
they hope to make.
Let's get them ready to do it.
Let's keep them in school.
Let's make schools they want to be in.
In order to learn how to
make their contribution.
And I think just one more thing.
I think the pandemic has
taught so many teachers
how much caring about
the students matters.
Being part of their lives matters.
How much being, integrating the school
with the community matters.
And, not just the teaching and testing.
But creating a culture that
makes students love learning.
And learn optimally.
- [Sal] Thanks, that's so inspiring.
Vicky.
- I guess reinforcing what Carol says is.
I want to say it can be done.
Yes, it can be done in the most isolated
and the most impoverished
areas of many of our countries.
It can be done.
We demonstrated that
with the UNESCO study.
The first comparative international study
of UNESCO in Latin America.
Years back, I think it
was in the year 2000.
Columbia and Cuba were
the only two countries
where rural schools
outperformed urban schools.
Except in the mega cities.
Demonstrated that yes,
we can reduce inequity.
It's possible.
But also, not only that.
But it compensates for
social economic inequalities.
This is what we wanted to demonstrate.
That it can be done.
But also, the children learn.
And the children love learning.
And they continue.
But because more of
the same is not enough.
I think this is important.
We really have to make
this change in education.
An I'm quoting someone that I heard.
And I always say, mention it.
Because people do not understand.
"If we bring a doctor
from a hundred years back
into a hospital today,
that doctor is lost."
Because everything has
changed permanently so much.
But if we bring a teacher
from a hundred years ago
into a classroom today.
Even in an elite school,
that teacher is not so lost.
Because everything has changed
except the way of learning.
So this is why this is
the powerful message.
It can be done.
But more of the same, it's not enough.
We have to make these changes.
- No.
Well, thank you both for
spending the time with us.
Honestly, for your decades
of incredible work.
Which I think is just getting started
on the impact on humanity.
I wanna special thanks to
"The Yidan Price Foundation."
Which has a mission of
creating a better world
through education.
Supports practices and education
for putting us all together.
We're all on this, what they
call "council of luminaries."
Which we're proud to serve on.
But, I looked at both of your work
for inspiration all the time.
When we're thinking through Khan Academy.
As you know, I was more
on listening mode today.
But everything that we stand for
is essentially what y'all stand for.
How do we give students agency?
How do we ensure that
teachers have the information
so that they can do more
focused work with students.
More human work with students.
Students can learn at
their own time and pace.
You need to measure, you need to assess.
But it shouldn't be a
statement on who you are.
It should just be a
statement on where you're at.
And so this, even the
social of mastery learning.
And if you're at an 80%, not a big deal.
Keep working on it.
Get to a 90%.
Get to a 100%.
Which it feels very closely aligned
with this notion of everything y'all do.
So thank you so much
for being part of this.
- Wonderful to be with you, Sal.
Wonderful to have met you a bit in person.
Thank you.
And hope to meet you someday in person.
- Nice to see you again.
- I'm going to give a
nice Latino "abrazo".
- Great to see you again, Sal.
- Great to see you also.
- Well, thanks everyone for joining.
As you can tell.
We could have spoken for several hours to
each of Carol and Vicky.
They really are titans in
the field of education.
And it actually turns out
that a couple of years ago.
I was at a restaurant.
And I saw them having, I'm
pretty sure it was Carol.
And it might've been Vicky as well.
And I was just like, "Oh,
they won't wanna talk to me."
But just right before this.
I said, "Hey, I saw
you at the restaurant."
Like, "Why didn't you come by?"
I was like, "I didn't
want to bother y'all."
But anyway.
They're two heroes of mine.
They've done profound work.
That's already impacted the world.
And I think is going to
only impact the world
more and more over the decades
and generations to come.
And as I mentioned.
Everything we do here at Khan Academy
is about trying to empower
exactly what they're up to.
In order for someone to
have a "growth mindset"
about learning.
They should be able to learn
at their own time and pace.
If they haven't mastered it.
Keep working on it.
That the role of the
classroom should not be
one way flow of information, lecture.
Everyone sitting passively silent.
It should be everyone working together.
Students working with each other.
The teacher walking around.
Forming human connections.
We should create ability
for students to have agency
over their own learning.
Which might be actually the
most important skill of all.
Even more important than
any of the academic skills.
So thank you for joining.
And hopefully you enjoyed
that conversation.
(upbeat music)